la parole est maintenant notre collègue
robert le flou pour les groupes les
républicains vous avez la parole mon
cher collègue président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des affaires
étrangères et du développement
international et porte sur le sommet
france océanie ainsi que l'évocation de
la situation des îles océaniennes au
cours de la coop 21 le quatrième sommet
france-océanie s'est tenue à paris le 25
26 novembre juste avant la coupe 21
on dira même des dirigeants océaniens
présent ce fut un succès instaurée en
2003 par le président chirac
ce sommet devait être un rendez-vous
triennale entre les gouvernements
oceania les trois collectivités
françaises du pacifique et le président
français le dernier avait eu lieu en
le suivant devait se tenir en 2012 hélas
rien ces six ans d'absence français sont
regrettables
tandis qu'au contraire les sommets
souvent annuel etats unis hausse et
nishino ceni japon s'est dit indigné
autres se sont multipliés l'océanie est
une zone stratégique ci souhaite donc
savoir dans quelle mesure la france
pourrait acter une véritable régularité
des sommet france-océanie peut-être
aussi au rythme le plus soutenu par
exemple tous les deux ans par ailleurs
cette coop 21 qui s'achève a mis en
avant la tragédie qui attend l'océanie
si les réfugiés de guerre ont l'espoir
de revenir un jour de revoir un jour
leur pays
les futurs réfugiés climatiques savent
qu'elles quitteront leur terre bientôt
englouti sans espoir de retour et je
comprends et je soutiens leurs
revendications leurs revendications dix
ans a ramené l'objectif à 1,5 degré de
réchauffement
la france puissance océaniennes par ces
collectivités du pacifique dont
j'aimerais savoir si elles pourront
bénéficier du fonds vert
at elle porté la voix des océaniens
pendant la coupe 21 et si oui de quelle
manière
je vous remercie merci pour nous
répondre la parole et le secrétaire
d'état chargé des affaires européennes
et nos trois collectivités appartiennent
à l'europe
absolument je vous remercie monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur robert l'eau folle
où le quatrième sommet france océanie a
marqué comme vous l'avez dit une
nouvelle étape dans les relations de la
france avec ses voisins océaniens et il
a permis de renforcer les liens non
seulement d'amitié mais aussi
économiques scientifiques et culturels
qui unissent nos peuples et vous avez
raison de rappeler que l'océanie et
cette région est absolument stratégique
pour les grandes questions
internationales donc ce sommet a été
utile les pays de cette zone qui sont
très vulnérables aux dérèglements
climatiques ont pu exprimer leurs
demandes
elles concernent principalement deux
points sur lesquels la france a apporté
son soutien tout au long de la coque au
pays de l'océanie premièrement le niveau
d'ambition de l'accord et en particulier
son expression en terme de limites de la
hausse de la température à moins de 2
degrés comme vous l'avez dit la
revendication et même de la limiter à un
degré 5 comme vous le savez les petits
états insulaires en développement
c'est le cas de nombreux pays du
pacifique sont particulièrement
vulnérables est impacté par la montée
des eaux
c'est leur survie qui est en jeu
deuxième point l'adaptation ce que l'on
appelle les pertes et dommages c'est à
dire les soutiens pour faire face aux
conséquences du dérèglement climatique
la france en tant que présidence de la
coop s'est fait d'abord l'avocat de ces
pays elle cherche une solution
ambitieuse elle est très attentive aux
demandes des pays vulnérables en général
et donc ces deux sujets font l'objet de
travaux haddock et de consultation
spécifique qui se poursuivent
aujourd'hui encore la france poussent
aussi pour des solutions concrètes à ces
enjeux et porte une initiative sur le
renforcement des systèmes d' alerte aux
risques climatiques que l'on appelle
cruz et pour lequel a été levé 80
millions d'euros vous avez raison de le
relever
un dialogue continu des réunions
périodiques doivent permettre de
continuer à resserrer nos liens
le président de la république a donc
fait part de l'engagement de l'état à
tenir un cinquième sommet france océanie
en 2018
l'engagement également été pris devenir
des dialogues biennaux
de haut niveau entre la france et la
présidence du forum des îles pacifique
vous m'interrogez enfin sur
l'éligibilité des collectivités
françaises du pacifique au fond vert
celui ci est exclusivement réservé aux
pays en développement mais des projets
régionaux avec des impacts positifs pour
les collectivités seront évidemment
développé jour merci merci monsieur lui
dis-je